hundreds of ultra-nationalist Jews are
carrying out incursions into the Al-Aqsa
mosque complex in occupied East
Jerusalem big crowds of mostly young
settlers raised provocative slogans and
entered the mosque compound for a third
day on Tuesday to Mark a season of
Jewish holidays they're being escorted
by the Israeli police Israeli forces
have set up military checkpoints in the
old city and imposed restrictions on
Palestinian worshipers the Jordanian
walk for Islamic trust that manages the
compound has criticized the incursions
Rob Reynolds has more from occupies
Jerusalem
we are in the Old City and the occupied
East Jerusalem and this is about as far
as we can get to the area where uh
people are entering the uh Al-Aqsa
mosque area including uh Ultra
nationalists who've been entering during
this Jewish holy week and Jewish uh
holiday of Sukkot they've been entering
in larger numbers you can see here the
police checkpoint which is uh preventing
uh some people from entering including
some Muslims who've been asked to move
to a different area but we've also been
requested to move along here by the
Israeli police so we're just going to
move up here
the tensions have been rising here
because during Secaucus this
week-long holiday uh alternationalist
Jews have been entering the Temple Mount
which they call the Temple Mount which
others call the Al-Aqsa compound in
larger than usual numbers they are
allowed to enter according to various
protocols that have been developed over
the years but they're not supposed to
pray and some of the people that we've
talked to in the ultra Nationals
Community here say that they do intend
to pray as a way of sort of establishing
a Jewish presence also the Palestinian
Authority has
protested and condemned the Israeli
police presence in the Al-Aqsa area and
called upon the United States to take
responsibility for putting pressure on
Israel to put a halt to this warning
that the entire situation could become
so provocative as to detonate in the
words of the Palestinian Authority with
unpredictable consequences Rob Reynolds
Al Jazeera in occupied East Jerusalem